there is actually a reason to get
excited people on YouTube who are now
yawning and checking their watches and
wondering why you're not watching
whatever Netflix show you're currently
watching I'm gonna make this exciting
for you but it hinges on our opponent
now not resigning and number two not
doing anything ridiculous taking on C2
like a good boy
very good step two to go King H7 like a
good boy and not King h8 let's see
actually I can there we go step three
we're gonna go Bishop to C8 this move
might strike you as a little bit
mysterious but hopefully some of you can
see what I'm setting up
[Music]
let's go to those watching on YouTube I
apologize for my voice I'm super
congested
getting over an illness so please bear
with me I apologize for for the way I
sound
we got the show on the road 1570 is our
opponent's rating
and we have the white pieces let's go
for the jugular with E4 and we are
facing a perk or as uh is properly
pronounced the Pierce p-i-r-c now D6 is
the gateway to the periods but it's not
only the gateway to the Pierce there's a
couple of other openings that stem from
this move and we will see what our
opponent chooses our move of course is
D4 and the perk is Knight F6 followed by
G6 you can also transpose into the
philodor with the movie five so there's
a major fork in the road and our
opponent does indeed opt for the pirates
with G6 I guess I should pronounce it
properly or I'm going to get some
pushback probably on YouTube
so G6 is the appearance and one way to
think about this opening is kind of like
the the cousin of the king's Indian
black plays the same exact King's Indian
setup except he does it against one E4
and the chief difference between the
Pierce and the King's Indian is that in
the king's Indian White has a Pawn on C4
so imagine the C2 Pawn moving up to C4
you literally have a king's Indian now
you might ask well who does this benefit
who does the fact of the pawn being on
C2 actually benefit and the answer in my
mind is pretty unequivocal the king's
Indian has a far superior reputation to
the pierce the Pierce is not played
often at a high level it is considered a
very dubious opening but at the same
time it's eminently playable at lower
levels it hasn't been refuted there
isn't one agreed upon refutation or line
against the appearance the reason that a
lot of top players do not play it is
that white has four or five or even more
continuations that reliably give white a
sizable advantage and there's two
buckets of ways to play against the
Pierce there are tactical or attacking
continuations you might have seen the
Austrian attack with F4 you might also
be familiar with like Bishop E3 and F3
the English attack setup is also very
good against the Pirates but the line
that I have always played with white and
the line that I think gives nightmares
to a lot of Pierce players who want a
tactical struggle who want opposite side
castling and a lot of action is the
classical variation that was favored by
Anatoly karpov and that is still favored
by I would argue almost a majority of
Grandmasters today and this is a very
calm developmental approach which may
seem unambitious but do not confuse this
with a lack of ambition this is actually
one of the most dangerous weapons that
you can Trot out against the Pirates and
the classical is defined by the very
modest developing move Bishop to E2
which goes against seemingly all of the
developmental principles that I've been
teaching thus far in the speed run but
give this line a chance so I won't delve
too deeply into the kind of philosophy
behind why specifically you go Bishop E2
why not Bishop D3 why not Bishop C4
there are reasons for that and I'll talk
about them after the game for now all
you have to know is that in the
classical variation white goes kingside
and black goes kingside so
the battle at least in the next
immediate future is not going to revolve
around opposite side castling and who
can Checkmate who first it's going to
revolve around whether or not we can use
our Superior central control and and
transform it into a more tangible a more
concrete Advantage black response with a
move C5 this is one of the most
principled continuations against the
appearance and again we have a fork in
the road we can play D takes E5 and keep
the center open or or we can play this
benoni style and push D5 as far as I
know the principled line and this is
where kind of you can see that the
limits of my own my own theoretical
limitations I haven't studied this line
in a while so my knowledge is like many
many years old and we'll look at this
after the game but we're gonna go
principled we're gonna go D5 we're going
to say I want to keep a sizable share of
the center and it's entirely possible
that my opponent is going to know more
Theory than me black plays the move E6
slicing into our Center and offering us
a trade on E6
so apparently C5 is not a move says uh
Jeffrey Jean I will be totally honest I
don't know C5 that well I'm sure it's
been played a good amount
uh but we'll look at it more carefully
after the game maybe the move is just D
take C5 and Bishop E3 I'll be learning
along with you okay so black plays E6
how are we going to react to this
how are we going to react to this well
let's think about this for a second
um we can play D take C6
and the upshot or the positive of that
move is that we leave black with a
relatively weak Pawn on E6 but we also
can just keep the tension and continue
developing our pieces with a move like
Bishop F4 we're not really afraid of
black taking on D5 we'll just recapture
with our pawn and what I like about that
approach if we put our Bishop on F4 if
we put our Bishop on F4 we are
pressuring the pawn on D6 and we're
making it kind of difficult for black to
develop the Knight because Knight beat a
D7 blocks the connection between the
queen and the pawn and allows us to win
the pawn on D6 so Bishop F4 looks at I
like the move Rook to E1 kind of just a
flexible waiting move you know what else
I like the move a2a4 just expand a
little bit on the queen side make it
difficult for black to push B5
eventually so lots of options here for
white Bishop G5 also looks perfectly
sufficient
um essentially like maybe four or five
lines that I think are about equivalent
let's go Bishop F4 this is my initial
inclination and if you're looking at
this kind of for the first time you
might wonder why isn't E5 good for black
this move now comes with Tempo and now
we actually do get kind of a very Kings
Indian type of structure and I could
talk about this for 11 minutes there's a
lot to explain here because the center
is close and as I've been saying since
the start of the speed run closed Center
positions are the hardest to teach in
terms of actual instruction and showing
you the ideas these types of structures
are very difficult because there's a lot
of explanation there's a lot of
maneuvering but for now what I'm going
to say is that in the king's Indian as
in these structures one of Black's main
plans is to move the Knight away from F6
and then push the pawn to F5 you've
probably seen this idea if you've seen
any Kings Indian games so what we're
going to do for starters is try to make
it as difficult as possible for black to
execute the play plan with F7 F5 in the
meantime we are going to try to make our
own series of improvements in our
position if you play the benoni from the
white side who in the chat can tell me
what White's main maneuver is in the
benoni this is a maneuver that you have
to be familiar with and we are going to
carry this maneuver out in this position
as well exactly Dirk and Dirk got it
it's the night maneuver from F3 back to
D2 and then to C4 the C4 Square as I'll
show you after the game in the benoni
and if you don't know what the benoni is
you're watching on YouTube that's okay
I'll show you that as well
just know that it's an opening that
bears a lot of similarities to what we
have here that night on C4 is a monster
piece and it's a monster piece because
the pawn on D6 is very far from a
monster we're gonna go Knight T2
now am I
yeah am i coughing yes am I blundering
the pot on B2 it may look that way but
if you look one move deeper then you
should see that after Queen takes B2 I
simply jump to B5 with the Knight with a
double threat there's Knight C7 there's
Knight takes D6 and of course Black's
Queen is also in significant trouble on
B2 so we really don't have to calculate
past Knight B5 also notice that after
Queen B2 Knight B5 the Knight on D2
serves a very important defensive
purpose it protects the E4 Pawn people
often blunder this pawn and kind of
nonchalantly move the Knight away from
C3 so important to keep the pawn on e4
protected because it's like the the
linchpin of our entire structure
so for the moment the Knight fulfills a
defensive role as well once it moves
into C4 we'll have to find alternate
arrangements for the defense of this
Pawn if we then want to play Knight B5
but we'll cross that bridge when we get
there
and that's why the queen on B6 may seem
like an imposing piece but in fact is
often much more of a liability than a
strength because Knight C4 now comes
with Tempo simply pushing the queen back
from B6
and our opponent fearlessly grabs
upon on B2 wow
all right I'm calling our opponents
Bluff Knight B5 here we go
this already looks borderline losing we
might not even have to talk about the
pod on D6 at all we might simply want to
trap black screen here I'm still
thinking about ways to do that but I've
got a couple of promising leads
so there's there's a lot of moving Parts
in this position what you need to
understand is that first of all there
was the threat of Knight C7 so if we
wanted to play like an old Soviet
Grandmaster I don't care about
calculation I'm gonna simply take 0.96
and I'm much better right so after
Knight takes D6 it's black is collapsing
right without the pawn on D6 we have a
monster passer on D5 the queen is still
bad no question that Knight takes D6 is
like a huge Advantage for right but we
have to think more ambitiously because
we have a golden opportunity to trap the
queen on B2 and if we play Knight takes
D6 we potentially let the queen out to
be sick so that game is going to last a
while so let's think
I actually have to think I I don't see
the best way to trap the queen just yet
aha
I might have found it I think I did
okay I think I found it
um so
here's the thing when you're trying to
trap the queen my biggest piece of
advice is to start by identifying
evacuation routes okay first question
you should ask yourself is if I make a
waiting move
can my opponent evacuate their Queen now
the answer in this case is yes black can
evacuate their Queen through before and
then A5 and then d8 so your initial
inclination should be some move that
whatever else it accomplishes covers the
B4 Square so most of you are coming up
with the move Rook B1 but you cannot
forget that when you move pieces you
leave other pawns undefended so after
Rook B1 black plays Queen takes A2 same
question are there evacuation routes
there are the queen now threatens to
jump back to A5 and move back to d8 so
we come up instead with a quiet move can
we simply deprive black of the B4 Square
can we get rid of it yes we can we can
play the quiet move A3 this I think is
the key to the kingdom but that's only
step one step two is to actually trap
the queen right we've encircled it how
do you trap the queen well if you look
carefully enough it's a pretty
straightforward forward sequence of two
moves it's Rook to B1 forcing the queen
to A2 and then Bishop to C4 actually
traps the quid on A2
and our opponent Kudos is trying to
extricate the queen at all costs Bishop
G4 is a very ingenious defensive move
but we are prepared for that eventuality
what's the move yeah we just play F3 we
just set the bishop back and notice that
the Knight on B5 is is a hero it's
guarding D4 it's covering the B file and
it's defending A3 and it's defending C3
the Knight is literally doing five
things to ensure that the queen is
trapped which is what I love about Chess
like a random piece can be the entire
reason that you're winning a particular
game I don't see a way for black to save
his Queen maybe something exists
now in this in these situations
another thing that you have to be very
careful about is something I've talked
about before which is that it's not
enough to just trap the queen you also
have to make sure that you are not
giving away too many pieces for the
queen and I will remind you after the
game of a very painful example from my
uh early early Chester where I did
exactly that I found a very similar idea
I trapped my opponent's queen and I
ended up giving away a rook and and like
three pieces for it
um and what good is that if your
opponent has overwhelming material for
the queen
so something that you always should
watch out for here I think the most the
black can get for the queen is a rook
right if you think about it Rook B1
the best the black can do is just take
that rook and Rook for a queen is
nothing in most cases so our opponent is
struggling here I don't see a way out
yeah Bishop H5 is is is tantamount to
resignation we can safely proceed with
our strategy Rook B1
and resignation here is not unlikely
and notice that we didn't actually end
up using the pod on D6 at all right we
focused on the Queen We trapped it and
the pawn on D6 is going to fall
but only after we trapped the queen
yeah a simple but elegant is a good
characterization
we have Grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang in the
chat for those watching on YouTube
and again I feel the need to step up my
game which is awesome
but an elegant illustration I think of
just the danger of capturing upon on B2
but a lot of people they they carry this
and make it into a dogma and they never
take a pot on the second rank with their
Queen which is also wrong in many many
cases I can show you a million examples
where players like completely Bluff and
taking on B2 is not only possible but
just wins the pawn because the queen can
easily evacuate trapping the queen is
actually an incredibly hard process that
involves a ton of moving Parts as you
can see here like look at how many
Parts there are in this mechanism
there's The Rook Knight upon the other
night and the bishop without
even a single one of these pieces or
pawns this would not have worked so
think about that for a second right
that's three six nine
14 15 points of material in order to
trap the queen on like the most
vulnerable Square on the chessboard so I
think in my experiences with like Club
players I found that players tend to be
very scared about let's say taking a
Pawn on B2 and they take for granted
that the queen is going to get trapped
but actually trapping the queen is an
incredibly incredibly hard thing to do
just something to to
marinade on
it takes the village and now now that
we're up a queen now it becomes very fun
to carry out the ideas that we were
planning to carry out before we won the
queen but we don't even have to do that
right we have some low-hanging fruit
that we can pick off we have some
low-hanging fruit that we can pick off
we can play night C4 as is the custom in
these positions but wait a second notice
that the bishop is trapped
and this is the sort of concept of
making mental notes to yourself that
I've talked about in a previous game
excuse me this is what happens when I
talk a lot
Bishop H5 was played you have to hold
these two things in your mind at the
same time yes we were focusing on
trapping the queen but I made a quick
mental note to myself that the bishop is
also trapped and that you should look
for G4 later on now it's time for that
G4 is on the table and we win another
minor piece and I think our opponent
might resign here
okay
give me give me give me that Bishop
and now everything falls and now now
that we are up a queen and a piece for a
rook is it finally time
is it finally time wait maybe it's still
not finally time because we actually
have a kind of cute tactic here
does anybody see the cute tactic
there there's a nice little tactic that
that would be a good way to end the game
with a flourish we we don't even have to
start with Knight C4 we can go straight
for the jugular here no not F4 F4 is the
kind of move
I get the temptation of f4 and it opens
up the king side but it doesn't really
accomplish all that much F4 Knight takes
F4 what have you really achieved other
than a major trade in opening up Black's
bishop and I know it's absurd to talk
about this stuff since we're up so much
material but as I've said before you
still want to build good habits in how
you convert these types of positions
yeah Knight takes D6 very nice a lot of
you are getting it this is a simple
tactic but not as simple as it may
appear because if you actually calculate
Rook takes D6 the idea is Queen takes B7
so this is of the category deflection
right we are deflecting The Rook from D6
and the secondary theme is Fork after
Queen takes B7 we are forking the Knight
on The Rook but the line does not end
there if you keep calculating black has
the move Rook A8 to B8 maybe some of you
saw this and this freaked you out but
you still can't stop calculating the
Knight is hanging on A6
the night is the only piece that's
guarding the Rook on B8 so all we have
to do is keep in contact with the Rook
what do we do after Rook B8 well there
was really only one move and its Queen
takes a seven and black has no good way
to keep the Knight protected and keep
the Rook protected at the same time
black is going to lose the Knight back
on A6 and we are going to end up having
won three more pawns actually
yeah there is the move Rook B to B6 I
don't know how many of you are
visualizing that Rook B8 Queen takes A7
there is the move Rook bb6 but after
Bishop takes A6 Rook takes A6 we give a
back rank check on B8 we force the
bishop back to f8 and Bishop to E7 is
gonna finish off the game hopefully that
actually happens so I can display this
on the board but I did see that when I
was taking on D6
or or we can just play Knight C4 and
that would be maybe the most symbolic
way to end the game for the last move of
the game to actually be Knight C4 is
kind of cute wouldn't you say but here I
don't think it's meant to be we're just
gonna take back the Knight on A6
and on the next move we're gonna jump
into C4 and that's gonna finish it off
yeah this is total Destruction I really
don't know why our opponent is playing
on
this is utterly one-sided
yeah this is this is utterly utterly
one-sided
black literally has no pieces left to
mean
no Queen no minor pieces no Pawn on D6
and this is definitely a downside I
think in the 15 plus 10 speed run we
didn't have the same problem
in the 10 minute timer where people you
know some people they they take their
time to resign
and at some point I basically exhaust
all of the the topics in the position H6
okay let's drop the bishop back to E3
attacking C5 still trying to be as
clinical as possible
we could have also played we could have
also played Knight C4 of course as an
intermediate move
Bishop d8 even was possible yeah Bishop
d8 was a cute move but no need to be
overly fancy just play Simple chess
then that's the fastest way to convince
your opponent of the futility of their
resistance
so Knight C4 is dext
notice that the Rooks are attached
and if they become disattached then you
lose the Rook on B8 That's The Power of
contact between pieces
Rook B1 okay so we're up a million
points in material so we basically make
a b line for simplification we trade on
B1 and then the fastest way to actually
win this is just to promote the d-pawn d
d 6078
and that's often the case when you're up
like a ridiculous amount of material you
want to start by looking for checkmate
and in the absence of an obvious check
Manning pattern which there actually is
in this position if you wanted to go for
checkmate then you would go Knight D6
and aim for the F7 Pawn
so either way the game ends very quickly
um hey let's go for me let's let's go
for the
the immediate win with Knight D6
oh
so okay I see a beautiful mating
construction let's see if I can make
this happen
just watch all right there's actually a
reason to get excited people on YouTube
who are now yawning and checking their
watches and wondering why you're not
watching whatever Netflix show you're
currently watching I'm gonna make this
exciting for you but it hinges on our
opponent now not resigning and number
two not doing anything ridiculous taking
on C2 like a good boy
very good step two to go King H7 like a
good boy and not King h8 let's see
actually I can there we go step three
we're gonna go Bishop to C8 this move
might strike you as a little bit
mysterious but hopefully some of you can
see what I'm setting up
some of you can see what I'm setting up
now don't move your knight please I am
begging that you look at this past pawn
and you say I'm gonna push that pass
Pawn up to C4 okay it's not that nice
but it's kind of cute yeah a lot of you
guys are seeing what I'm setting up it's
it's I won't reveal it I won't reveal it
on I
that's that's now that's just nasty that
that's just unacceptable Behavior by my
opponent
the idea of course was Queen takes G6
check and Bishop to F5 Checkmate I'll
show you after the game and the Knight
is essential there because it's blocking
the king's escape to H5
okay now you should never be afraid well
you should sometimes be afraid of this
type of mechanism when there's a rook on
the second Rank and there's a knight on
the third rank that is part of a
broader pattern that you have to be
familiar with where sometimes if the
rook and the Knight are arranged on the
proper squares there is a Perpetual
check mechanism that can be delivered
with an infinite amount of night checks
but this is not one of those mechanisms
here if you look carefully 92 check is
not really a threat we just go kf1 and
then ke1 and King D1 the Knight has no
way of corralling the king the king
escapes to D1 so we can safely proceed
with our mating operation and play 98
which is the simplest move and the way I
found it is that the moment the Knight
left H5 you consider the drawback you
say oh well it it leaves the bishop now
undefended and we can hit it with our
Knight
now don't go King H1 because after
Knight G3 check then you're going to be
forced to go back to G1 right that's a
dead end
what's not a dead end is to go to E1
yeah maybe our opponent plays Knight H5
and then maybe I should go Knight D6 and
try to set up the tactic again okay
rookie two check that doesn't help King
D1 and that's it
that's all sure this should be
resignation
yeah definitely frustrating Knight H5
we're gonna just take the Rook on E2
no definitely tenacious
and and I'm not in any way suggesting
that
there's something wrong with you know
playing it's your right to play It's
Your Right to spend your time
so I think some people are a little bit
too extreme on oh you know my opponent
took longer than you know he should have
to resign
you know what a what a disgraceful bad
Sportsman I I really don't think that
you should overreact but you know for
sure some players take longer to resign
than others GG
all right so our main focus in this game
is actually going to be on the opening I
want to outline kind of a general
overview of the perk and explain why I
think this line is very very good now in
the speed run overall I'm recommending
very tactical very Dynamic openings I'm
looking at the Vienna against D5 we're
also going to play the fortnite scotch
against C5 you know that I recommend the
alapen so very sort of combative head-on
continuations but you want to save your
energy in chess and the the Pierce is is
relatively speaking a a rare opening
right so the what I advise to students
is is to spend you know like the 80 20
rule right to spend 80 percent of your
effort on the the 20 of openings that
occur most frequently when I say 20 I I
mean to suggest that like 20 of the
initial moves account for 80 of the
popularity or so I'm talking Sicilian
and E5 right that's actually 10 of
Black's legal Moves In the initial
position there are 20 legal moves E5 and
C5 occur far more frequently than the
others so you have only so much effort
and energy and time to spend on openings
what you don't want to do is purchase
four books on the Puritan spend as long
learning D6 as you would learning C5 and
that is why against these Sidelines I'm
trying to propose variations that you
can basically learn in something like 30
minutes or you can learn them through a
single speedrun game which is ultimately
the goal of the speedrun and that's why
I'm not going to be playing the Austrian
attack with F4 which is uh ridiculously
theoretical line
you can argue that it's the most
principled and that if you really wanted
to fight for the biggest Advantage then
perhaps you should consider playing F4
although that's under debate that's
that's not set in stone or maybe you
should consider playing them Bishop E3
and queen D2 but these lines are
immensely theoretical Bishop E2 has its
share of theory but it's manageable you
can play it over the board even without
knowing any Theory as long as you know a
couple basic ideas
okay
so
first question why Bishop E2 well the
reason that we don't bring the bishop
out to C4 in these types of positions is
is tactical right after after we have
mutual castles black has the center fork
trick which I've talked about many times
and you certainly do not want to walk
into a knight take C4 already
essentially equalizes for black
because after D5 the only way for white
to keep the light squared Bishop on the
board and avoid losing a pawn who can
tell me what very typical move white
should play here if you've fallen for
this then you should Salvage the Bishops
by playing the move Bishop to D3
but after de Bishop takes E4 black can
prepare C7 C5 black can play it
immediately or black can play Knight D7
and C5 and as far as I know white might
have a minuscule tiny Edge in a position
like this but it's really nothing major
so you don't want to go Bishop C4 for
that reason a lot of people actually do
go Bishop D3 and this is not a great
move and the reason why is that you're
essentially inviting black to position
their Bishop on G4 and you might say
well I don't understand why that's
dangerous right let's say we have
castles castles can't I just play H3 and
you can and again I think White's gonna
be slightly better but Bishop G4 is
annoying in these types of positions
because the pod on D4 can get under some
very very serious pressure after Queen
takes F3 Knight C6
if you are forced to play the move D5
then you have Justified the placement of
Black's Bishop you've given black a very
nice parking spot for for the Knight on
E5 and maybe the prospect of going C6 so
this should be making sense and if you
try to defend the pawn then what black
often does in the perk is move the other
night away and uh attack D4 from
multiple angles and again try to force
white to play D5 I'm going to show you a
really cute trick that was taught to me
many many years ago I can show you let's
see if I can actually find an example
of a strong player falling for this
trick this is the trick that flows from
exactly this position let's see what I
can find just a moment
I can almost guarantee you that
I can find some application of this
of this trick
yes I have very good so here is a 1900
falling for this exact trick oh and
almost this exact position against the
GM
and this way you'll you'll kind of
remember it for a long time
so we have literally the same exact
position
H3 Bishop F3 Queen F3 Knight C6 Bishop
B3 Knight d782 and here black plays a
very nonchalant move A6 and white says
okay let me support
the pawn on D4 with the move C3 what
could possibly be wrong with that white
is preparing
for The Logical move E5 but what does
black do
well you know that lpdo loose pieces
drop off what's the loose piece it's the
bishop on D3
and this is a very nice trick it's worth
knowing and the move of course is
pause the video if you're watching on
YouTube figure it out
yeah night any night to E5 exactly nice
little trick d595 pretty unconventional
actually for this type of idea to occur
in the opening
and that's it you win the bishop back
and you're up a full pawn and then at
night on D3 evacuates easily back
through E5 and as you can see black
ended up winning this game so just one
of those tricks that that's worth
knowing not saying that you're going to
catch a ton of people on it but
nonetheless hopefully you can begin to
see why positioning the bishop on E2 has
its strategic benefits because here can
black still play Bishop G4 absolutely in
fact Bishop G4 is one of Black's main
moves but after black takes on F3 it
doesn't create the same effect because
the queen is still making contact with
the D4 Pawn so it's much harder for
black to actually you know orchestrate
meaningful pressure on the D4 Pawn
because we can easily defend it with
Bishop E3
so in this position this is a critical
position this is what's called a tabia
t-a-b-i-y-a it's it's an Arabic term for
essentially a position a couple of Moves
In
from which flow you know six or seven
different theoretical continuations it's
like the starting point for a fork in
the road and there's a major fork in the
road
so black has a couple of ideas that are
aimed at expanding on the queen side and
almost all of them you meet with the
same move
the moment black plays C6 in the perk
you almost always play A4 you want to
prevent black from expanding on the
queen side with B5 B5 can be a very
nasty move to allow if you allow it then
all of a sudden you have a host of other
problems right you have to deal with B4
and then your E4 Pawn starts feeling
uncomfortable so it's worth just playing
A4 here and
normally I think Black Goes Knight B to
D7 in this line let me pull up chest
space and just double check to make sure
I'm giving you the right theoretical
information
mm-hmm
yeah Knight bd7
and here again I was taught this many
years ago by my coach so my knowledge
might be outdated here I was taught to
play H3 in this position
and then in the event the black plays E5
you're supposed to take it
take it
and then play uh and I just looked at
stockfish it is still the best move even
all these years later a very important
strategic move in this position should
be played does anybody know what it is
let's see who can figure this out in
chat
what is White's best move here it's
already plus over minus Black's position
is bad
so it's not rookie one rookie one is
just kind of a meh move
A5 is okay so a lot of you are attempted
by Queen D6 of course I understand why
but Queen D6 is not so scary because
black can go rookie it and then bishop
f8 and send the queen back although this
is a worthwhile idea to remember the
move is actually Bishop B2 to C4
and the idea is quite simple you're
actually just trying to make it as
difficult as possible
for black to develop their bishop and
you might say well I don't get it aren't
we allowing a move with Tempo and that's
only if you think one move into the
future this is simply a one move threat
after the trade of Queens the bishop
drops back to A2 and black is
experiencing massive problems with his
Queen side development the bishop simply
has nowhere to go this is the reason we
actually played H3
it can't go to G4
I mean it can't really go to D7 because
black just dropped C5
and well going to E6 is bad for many
reasons but mostly it's because what is
this POS in the center and on the king
side and white can continue the queen
side expansion with A5
so Knight B6 doesn't solve any problems
of course the Knight can also jump out
to C5 but this is also bad again Queen
trade followed by Knight G5 and Bishop
E3 black is just collapsing on all sides
here
so this is just a flat out unpleasant
position for black after Bishop C4 black
has ways to deal with this the top
engine move here is actually H6 which
says a lot about how bad the position is
if you have to play H6 that's how
cramped you are and after A5 black is
even more cramped
so this is a no-go for black and that's
why I think more recently in this
position people have been delaying the
movie five they've been playing in in
more of a cagey way with Queen C7 and
sometimes B6 but obviously black is
slightly worse white is the better
Center black is cramped and you can
develop with Bishop E3 here and after B6
I think a very simple plan is just to
play Queen D2 and then just go rookie
one and Rook D1 and potentially Bishop
H6 in order to trade off uh the the
puritz bishop on G7 but you don't have
to rush that move right I would position
my Rooks in the center first White is
solidly better here
so that's one of the main lines of of
the Pierce and there's many others I
won't talk about all of them right now
I will mention that
if black plays the immediate E5
which which some people do this is a
line
uh then white is actually supposed to
take on E5
and then take on E5 again
and this leads by force to an end game
where it's not that white is up upon
white is not up a pawn because black can
win the pawn back with this very typical
Knight take C4 technique and here you
can really see the commonalities between
the Pierce and the King's Indian they
share a lot of traits in common these
two openings if you think about the
king's Indian In The Exchange variation
you have the same exact idea it's a
different variation but the bishop's
still on E2
and in the exchange if white grabs on E5
myopically then black will take back
with Knight take C4
and by the way something worth knowing
if you're a Kings Indian player if white
plays Knight takes F7 here a secondary
Desperado who can tell me why this
doesn't work for white
a little bit of a detour but still worth
knowing
so not Knight takes C3 no no no because
then you blunder The Rook on d8
but the move is Bishop takes C3 check
and my coach I actually said I think a
very wise phrase which is that
well I think traditionally the hardest
move to see in chess is supposed to be a
retreating night move but he thought
that the hardest move to see in chess is
actually a move where you give up your
fee and kettled Bishop for a night those
types of moves produce a very visceral
aesthetic because you normally don't
want to do that right you don't want to
give up your fiancado Bishop at all so
often you're not actually thinking about
moves like Bishop G7 takes C3 if there
is a knight on C3 in this case it's
obvious why you do it it's a check and
now you can take on F7 and the Knight is
no longer hanging but I could show you a
couple of really cool positions or even
very strong players failed to recognize
like a sudden capture with the theme
kennode bishop and since we're on the
topic
here's a good example we're taking a
little bit of a tour through various
topics but hopefully you'll forgive me
that luxury Okay so
this is the game got a kamski against
tibia a very young gotta kamski his
birth date is 74 so he was 12 years old
but God at 12 years old is probably
already bastard definitely already
Master strength maybe even I am strength
and in this position typical accelerated
Dragon nothing out of the ordinary he
plays The Very typical move 92 to D4
inviting a trade of of minor pieces it
looks like white is better in fact black
is winning
let's see who can figure out why this is
really worth considering if you're a
higher rated player this is going to be
very stimulating exercise for you so
make sure to pause the video try to
figure it out
back to play
black wins by force
no Bishop A6 lunders a lot of pieces
yeah Chris Tower got it the first move
and this is what
kamski obviously missed is Bishop takes
Knight now why in God's name
would you take on D4 with the bishop now
if you want to take on D4 twice that's
different but taking on D4 twice is not
impressive white is better here
you have to see the follow-up right this
move is meaningless if not for the
follow-up and sphinxy got it E6
all of a sudden the Knight
has problems
it can't go to F6 you can go to E7 can't
go to B6 because it's protected
you go to B4 can't go to F4 because you
get forked so you have only one
available square but what was E3 doing
well E3 was supposed to be the
evacuation Square for White's bishop and
suddenly after E5 the bishop is trapped
you have only one available square and
that's A7
but after Rook B7
that's it the bishop is trapped white
loses a piece kamsky at least
he took a couple pawns he got active but
obviously the compensation is totally
insufficient here I think the second
very famous instance
of this happening recently was a game
between uh radislavoit and Fabiano
caruana a couple years ago where
Carolina took a knight on C3 but for
positional reasons it wasn't because he
was winning a piece he did it for
positional reasons and it was also it
really made the rounds of the Chess
World at the time you could Google that
game if you're interested but I you know
we've we've gone on enough of a detour
let's get back to the the actual
overview
okay
so where were we yeah I was talking
about the move E5
and what I wanted to say
or not E5 here E5 and the uh the perk
so we looked at we looked at C6 we're
looking at E5 and what I mentioned you
play Knight takes C5 immediately Knight
takes E4 Knight takes C4
and if Bishop takes E5 you trade on your
own terms you say listen I'm down to
exchange Queens but you're gonna have to
be the one taking on D1 and letting my
Rook occupy the open file so the move
here is Bishop to G5
classic and if black greedily takes the
pawn on B2 you should already sense
intuitively that this is just s-h-i-t
for black and I think the simplest move
here is to go C3 slicing off the
connection between the bishop and the F6
Square the Knight is jumping into F6
White's gonna get a huge attack you can
analyze this on your own but according
to the engine white is better here and
white is a big big practical initiative
as well
so
this is not a very good line for black
it doesn't solve all of its problems and
neither does C6 and neither does the
move that our opponent played which is
C5
which is C5 and I actually think that I
responded to that move correctly
I actually think that D5 the way that we
played
is uh very very decent
but it appears
that it was also possible to play D take
C5 I'm checking right now
and it looks like most people they do
play D5 yeah D5 is the main move here so
we made the right call
but D take C5 is an interesting
alternative DC DC and then you get the
bishop out to E3 and you attack the pawn
on C5
and after B6 it looks like there's a
very interesting line
where you actually go
E5
this is going to sound really weird you
go E5
so where is Black tonight
likely to go well Black Knight is going
to jump into G4 and now the engine gives
this crazy move
it's actually a novelty
and it's the move Queen E1
a ridiculous looking move but it should
actually make sense if you look at it
more deeply so the point is this first
of all if black takes on E5 he loses 95
Bishop E5 and Bishop F3 traps The Rook
in the corner another trick that's worth
knowing
and the idea is that if black takes on
E3 and after F takes E3 what is the
queen doing on E1 well the queen is
preparing to move into H4 with a direct
attack on the H7 Pawn furthermore you
have vacated the D1 Square for The Rook
right Rook ad1 is now going to come with
Tempo and then the Knight can jump into
D5 so White's gonna get an avalanche
here pretty darn quickly so apparently
the move Knight to C6 gives black just
enough to keep the balance but it looks
really really dangerous I'm looking at
the top Engine line and it goes here
here here I mean who wants to play this
with black and now this move
to threaten takes and takes this
actually looks very nasty from a
practical standpoint so I suppose that D
takes C5 is is also a full-fledged
alternative but we decided on the
principled move which is D5
and after E6 this is where my
theoretical knowledge ended I actually
don't know what the best move is here
but it does look like according to the
engine we chose the best line Bishop F4
and it makes sense because this move is
really really logical
we're essentially forcing black to
decide because if black makes a waiting
move then what happens well we already
take on E6 and then we take on D6 right
so we are literally forcing black to
make a decision in the center
and in the event of a trade we have an
excellent position we have pressure on
D6
but the most important thing to know
about these structures really the only
thing that you need to know is the
maneuver that I mentioned from the
benoni Knight F3 to D2 to C4 and the
original
instantiation of this maneuver is in the
benoni the benoni is an opening within
the Queen spawn game that goes C5 and E6
and all you have to know about it right
now is that once again you get a very
similar structure and the main line as
you can guess is indeed to play Knight
F3 to D2 and later on to jump into C4
so that
particular maneuver is crucial and it's
even stronger here because in the benoni
there is a Pawn on e4 that black can try
to attack here there's no E4 Pawn so
there's no obstructions to the Knight
getting into C4 black is in trouble how
do you meet A6 well you already know
that you want to go A4 that's the second
important thing to know do not allow
black to play B5 at any cost you have to
play A4 if black plays A6
and look at how hard it is for Black to
get their pieces out right Knight bd7
Bang
if you have to resort to this move well
this only makes Knight D2 stronger
because now Bishop takes D6 is an even
more powerful threat so I'm kind of
beating a dead horse here I think you
get the point this is a very unpleasant
position for black and the reason it's
unpleasant is because of the static
weakness static weakness is like this by
which I mean permanent weaknesses
weaknesses that are not easy to get rid
of
positions like these are very hard to
play because you're saddled with this
terrible Pawn potentially for the rest
of the game
and that makes it very unappetizing
so
in any case our opponent handled it
decently at first E5 Bishop G5 making it
hard for black to bring the Knight back
now what I want you to notice is that
after H6 we actually would have invited
black to play G5
why would we invite black to play G5
well
the thing is if you remember what I
mentioned Black's main idea on the king
side is to prepare F7 F5
and if the pawn is on G5 rather than G6
it's not that F5 is impossible black can
still absolutely move the Knight back by
all means black and play F5 but after e
takes F5 you want to have the ability to
recapture it with a pawn and keep the
Integrity of your punching if you have
to recapture with a piece then you have
given white these monster light squares
in the center and black just has no way
of continuing the pawn storm on the king
side this may seem imposing but look at
White's control over the light squares
on all three sides of the board E4 C4
but also just as importantly white
controls the H5 Square it's almost
impossible for black to push that h-man
forward and that means Black's play on
the king side is at a standstill whereas
White's play is only just getting
started Knight C4 the other night could
find a way to move to E4 you could play
a move like F3 in order to support the
E4 square with the Knight
you could play Bishop G4 and try to
trade the light scored Bishops which is
the best thing you can do if you give
get rid of Black's last defender of
light squares it's going to be a total
disaster
so
yeah black and go Knight H5 but that
doesn't change anything we still go
Knight D2 and we say big deal right
you've got a 9 out of four I don't care
you can just keep going in night on F4
alone is not really going to cause you
any trouble and it's not the greatest
thing to part ways with your own light
squared Bishop but it doesn't really
diminish the or change the character of
the position you can still do the same
thing you can go F3 and then you can go
94. and once you go F3 H5 is no longer
dangerous because H4 it doesn't trap the
bishop anymore you can just move back to
F2 and again just look at how terrible
Black's position is here
um
so in any case that's the idea of Bishop
G5 we're actually trying to provoke H6
and G5
um
so our opponent played Queen B6 if he
would have played A6 we would have
responded once again with A4 and on the
next move we would have maneuvered in
the Knight over to C4 perhaps even
considered the move F4 if black would
not have addressed the PIN
but in either case Black's position is
terrible our opponent of course
accelerated his demise by taking on B2
and after Knight B5 I think the game is
essentially over and the engine kind of
confirms this in a weird way in a weird
way the best move maybe was to actually
play Queen before but the thing is after
Knight C7 I don't even see a way for
black to win the night back I I think
black is going to be down a full Rook so
the engine actually gives the best move
as the pathetic Knight bd7
and here's what I mentioned if white
does the same thing that we did in the
game it's still possible
who can tell me
what is the difference between this
position and this position ignore the
placement of the bishop what additional
resource does black have here to keep
him in the game a little bit longer
yeah exactly black can take the Rook but
now black can take the Knight and here
black is actually a rook and a piece for
the queen is it bad is it losing yes
it's still losing because the Knight C4
idea is still devastating and Black's
pieces are still too passive but at
least black can keep the game going
unlike the game
so the last
detour the last thing that I'll show you
before I wrap up and getting pretty
exhausted in my voices literally going
as we speak
I've got commentary tomorrow so
I don't want to burn myself out too much
but this is a game that forever it
sounds dramatic but it really has stuck
with me for a long time because it's
such a
slam dunk illustration of this concept
and I've shown this game before
so you can recognize the type of
position there's a bad Queen on A3
and I spent if I remember correctly
maybe like 20 minutes trying to figure
out a way to trap the queen and I kept
thinking and thinking it was like maybe
I could go rugby three but then the
queen goes back to D6
and this is what I should have done I
should have done something like this and
basically said yeah I'm down a pawn but
look at my pieces but instead I thought
I was a genius I thought I found
something amazing
here's what I found
here's what I found
Knight B5
okay what the hell am I doing well the
idea is that after CB Bishop takes B5
check
Bishop D7 who can tell me what my idea
was this is before we get to the main
Crux of this example this isn't about
the idea that I came up with but how do
I actually trap his Queen
whoa Bishop before blood is the bishop
rugby three is still bad because of
Queen D6
the move is Knight C4 retreating Night
Moves I didn't mention that by accident
forcing the queen further into the
dungeon or so I thought and now you trap
it with Rook A1 Tada voila this is what
I calculated until
what did I forget about
and it's a trick question
there is a mukwa here a most popular
wrong answer there's a move I know
people will suggest in the chat which is
wrong
how does black get the most for the
queen
is Queen takes A1 most popular wrong
answer
because white has the intermediate move
Bishop takes Bishop check
and after Knight bd7 Queen you only have
a rook and a knight for the queen
nothing to write home about white is
better
the move is to play Bishop takes B5 and
then Bishop takes C4 and look at what
black has here black has three pieces
and a pawn and it's not just any pawn it
is a certified monster on A7 that's
going to land on A2 in like two seconds
and you'll see how quickly it happens
and if black wants to
black and capture on F1 but what's
amazing is my opponent didn't even take
that Rook my opponent decided that this
bishop is worth its weight in gold and
it is and it is because look at how it's
restricting all of White's pieces it's
keeping this Rook completely at Bay it's
protecting B5 it's controlling the light
squares in the center white has zero
active ideas zero while black has the
very simple plan of literally just
closing his eyes and pushing I did my
best I lifted my Rook up I desperately
sent my Pawn forward and now look at how
nicely black plays Rook F to E8
who can tell me the idea of this move
this is a lovely move this is a Master
Level move right here it's classy it's
not forced but it's it really is the
best way to eliminate White's counter
play and this is something that you
should remember
it's a defensive idea it's not an
attacking idea and we should probably
flip the board we should look at this
from Black's perspective sorry if that
kind of was nauseating
yeah it's to play night f8 now why on
Earth would you need to play Knight f8
Knight f8 no mate because after G5
Knight D5 Queen H5
we can play the move Knight f8
and since we're going down the Labyrinth
of
examples all of these examples that I
show if you truly want to be a a
diligent student of the game
then you should have a notebook or a
Word document or something where you
really just actually write down
a lot of these examples and a lot of
these ideas because you actually can
apply them in your games it this is not
like imaginary these are real Concepts
you could use them to enrich to enrich
your play the idea is to play Knight f8
and protect against Checkmate on H7 once
my opponent did that he can keep pushing
with A4
and A3 na2 bang here's another Fork
takes the Rook takes the pawn goes back
goes forward and here I resigned just
literally I have no pieces left and he's
got Total Domination good example of
Queen itis
forgetting that there is such a thing as
too many pieces for the queen but
the speedrun game is not one of them
obviously here black only got a rook for
the queen
once we played
A3 the game is over I literally cannot
find a single way for black to even so
much as give up a piece for the black
literally will lose the queen
and after F3 yeah the rest I think can
largely go without comment
remember low hanging fruit you trap the
bishop first you win all the pieces that
are hanging then you go for the tactics
and the last thing I wanted to say is
that after Rook B6 there was or actually
the penultimate thing I wanted to show
the the cool man at the end here I was
planning Bishop A6 Queen B8 and Bishop
to Esau another idea worth knowing not
Bishop H6 because the Knight can
intercept with G7 right so here
proximity is important
proximity means no interference or
interception tactics are possible
of course Knight C4 is also perfectly
sufficient and lastly if we fast forward
fast forwarding
the idea that I got so excited about if
black had played any other move Queen
takes G6 check is a really pretty mating
construction where all of the pieces are
necessary each minor piece is fulfilling
a particular role
so this this would have been a nice way
to end the game but our opponent ended
up allowing a more a more prosaic
Manning sequence
okay that was a pretty uh hectic like
Meandering analysis but hopefully you
enjoyed it I'm still under the weather
so it's hard for me to to be and I'm not
100 but you know still I hope you found
this worthwhile we did a good amount of
theoretical study I'm sure we'll face
the perk again so we'll get more of an
opportunity to delve into some of the
other lines in this position so there's
there's Knight C6 there's A6
there's uh even B6 I think is a move so
definitely a lot more to talk about in
in the purits and the modern which is
which is very similar to the Puritan
that's where black starts with G6
there's a couple subtle differences
these openings so more to learn but
hopefully you got the hang of the
classical variation Bishop B2 hopefully
you like it and you can you can start
playing it I mean there's really not
much that you have to know
and of course the moral of the story do
not forget in the benoni structure to
attack the D6 Pawn with Knight D2 and
Knight C4 and to meet A6 with A4 and
this is important both for E4 players
and for D4 players all right on that
note I'm gonna wrap up guys I'm gonna
pass out and like
three seconds
you make this content possible so all of
your subs and support is uh is is
instrumental thank you everybody and see
you tomorrow
[Music]